welcome everyone it is
my pleasure to introduce josh sainz as
this year's skullnick prize winner
the skulnick prize was endowed by a
generous gift from merck pharmaceuticals
in honor of ed skolnik who was president
of research labs for 17 years
i'd like to acknowledge the members of
the selection committee some of here
whom are here on the zoom seminar and
that includes bob horvitz and graybiel
nancy camwisher story landis joe coyle
catherine dulac and myself now
josh asked me to skip his biography
because he's planning to describe
some of his history in his own talk but
i just have an idea he's not going to be
talking about his own many awards and
honors so i'll just
mention a couple here that he's a member
of the national academy of science
the american academy of arts and
sciences he's received the aldon spencer
award the gruber neuroscience prize
and the cowan award for his work in
developmental neuroscience among others
now josh is one of a small group of some
of the most distinguished figures in
neuroscience
who have discovered most of what we know
about synapse development
and function beginning in the early
1980s he pioneered the use of molecular
and cellular biology
to understand the mechanisms that govern
synapse development at the neuromuscular
junction
including the analysis of intracellular
signals and intracellular responses
that coordinate the formation and
maturation
of the synapse he worked out the
mechanisms by which the presynaptic cell
helps orchestrate postsynaptic
differentiation
and how the postsynaptic cell promotes
presynaptic
differentiation he studied how a given
neuron forms a synapse with the correct
target among many possible choices in
development
including the key role of the n
coherence and synaptic adhesion
molecules
altogether he and his colleagues
and i just lost my place here um
all together he and his colleagues
provided much of the molecular support
for the chemo affinity hypothesis
pioneered by roger sperry
for how developing neurons find their
appropriate partners
during development during all this work
joshua
josh also became a major technical
innovator in neuroscience
introducing many of the molecular and
cellular methods used by neuroscientists
around the world
including many of the people on the zoom
call including the
recombinant retroviruses for tracing
cell lineage
and fluorescent transgenic mice for
visualizing neural connections including
the now famous
rainbow mouse finally in the most recent
phase of his career
josh has become one of the most foremost
anatomists of the retina
using single cell transcomics to
identify
many previously unknown cell types and
in a series of really elegant studies
has started to bridge the gaps
between gene expression anatomy neuronal
function
and even behavior
so we much very much look forward to
hearing josh tell us about his work
directly josh well thank you very much
um i'm really honored uh as you might
imagine by the receipt of this award
um and pleased to have the opportunity
to tell you about some of our research
it's especially meaningful in view of ed
skolnik's many contributions
and those of the eminences who preceded
me
before i start i also want to note how
much i admire the neuroscience community
at mit generally and at the mcgovern
institute in particular as we worked at
harvard to build cbs and hbi
um you guys have been an inspiration and
although i shouldn't say it
a source of occasional envy
now bob suggested that i include some
background
before telling you about recent projects
that's why i
asked him to minimize that part and i
decided to put together
a micro scientific autobiography as
prelude
to what you might rather hear and as i
did that i realized that my scientific
journey i hadn't quite appreciated this
before had a
strong ascending phylogenetic component
my first laboratory experience in fact
was um in late high school and early
college
in the laboratory of a wonderful man
named robert guthrie
in buffalo where i grew up and he had
developed bacterial assays for
detecting inborn errors of metabolism in
particular
phenylketonuria he was
ahead of his time in promoting science
education for students
and regularly invited students into his
laboratory
and gave us the quite unusual
opportunity to actually be useful
screening bacillus subtlest mutants that
could be used in new tests
then towards the end of college i had
the even more extraordinary opportunity
to work on protein kinases
in the laboratory of paul greengard who
was not only one of the
greatest molecular neurobiologists of
the last century
but also a brilliant and loving man who
remained a friend and mentor
to me until his death just under two
years ago
now i went to paul greengard's
laboratory because my interest in
neurobiology began
with the desire to learn something about
the biological basis of mental illness
which was really also what motivated
paul
when i got to graduate school though it
became apparent
that available methods really weren't up
to the task and so i
turned to developmental neurobiology
with a sort of vague idea which now
turns out to be likely true that
many psychiatric diseases may be
neurodevelopmental diseases
particularly diseases in which something
goes wrong with synaptic development
so for my phd thesis i climbed up
to uh manduka sexta working
on sensory neurons and their development
as the
manduka caterpillar turns into the
beautiful
manduka moth and my advisor there was
john hildebrand who i
always thank for being especially kind
and understanding of me at a time when i
was far
more obnoxious and high strung than i am
today
now during thesis um i took advantage of
the opportunity to get closer to
synaptic development by arranging a
postdoctoral fellowship
that began with work on the
neuromuscular junction of the frog
ronipipians with jack mcmahon
and continued with molecular
inquiries into the neuromuscular
junctions development with zach hall at
ucsf
now turning to rodents rats and mice
and i've continued to use mice as our
main
model animal ever since although
recently i must say we've begun to look
at non-human and human primates
but i hasten to add only postmortem and
only their eyes
now starting with post-doctoral work
and continuing as a faculty member at
washington university and more recently
at harvard
i focused really in large part on
synaptic development
with just small forays into other
developmental areas such as
neuronal lineage and migration and for
many years
decades really at washu we stuck with
the neuromuscular junction but
eventually moved up the near axis to the
retina
which has become our exclusive model
over the past decade
now the reason we use the neuromuscular
junction the synapse made by motor
neurons on skeletal
muscle fibers is that despite the fact
that it's a peripheral synapse and
doesn't even have a neuron as its
postsynaptic component
has a muscle fiber it has
advantages that just were not shared
with central synapses that we and
everybody else would have far
rather studied those advantages
include accessibility a lot of knowledge
about a structure and function
maybe preeminently its large size
which made it possible to assay a lot of
developmental manipulations by light
rather than electron microscopy
and i think you can see that here on the
right with a micrograph of a
neuromuscular junction in a mouse and
three hippocampal
synapses in a mouse all at the same
magnification
and we use this system then
to look into initially a phenomenon that
had been described
a century earlier actually and that is
that
when one cuts the motor nerve supplying
a muscle
the axons regenerate and form new
synapses
with more than 95 percent of them
forming at original synaptic sites
even though those sites occupy only a
tenth of a percent
between a tenth of a percent and a
percent of each muscle fiber surface so
this is a remarkable example of
subcellular specificity and as such
was something i really wanted to look
into given
this interest in how synapses wire up
the nervous system
and ultimately how they may miswire in
ways that could explain some
behavioral or even neurological diseases
so we looked into this um again this
began as a postdoctoral fellow
and found that some of the critical
determinants that axons recognize are
not
in the muscle or on its plasma membrane
but rather
in the synaptic cleft that
intervenes between the nerve terminal
and a postsynaptic
muscle fiber membrane a basal lamina
that's specialized in this particular
region
now washington university this work gave
us a place to look and we began looking
for
molecules within the synaptic cleft that
could account for this precise
reinnervation
and we were then able to look at roles
that these molecules and their receptors
played in
normal synaptic development and that
project was made possible
um thanks to a long intense and very
uh life-altering for me collaboration
with john murley that lasted for more
than a dozen years
until his untimely and sudden death from
a heart attack in 1995.
now john was a pioneer in applying
genetic engineering to neuroscience
uh generating transgenic and then knock
out mice to answer questions about
neural development he taught me all i
know about that
and then starting together and continue
after his death
we ended up analyzing something like 40
genes using knockout technology
ones that encoded components of the
synaptic cleft which is where we started
some of their pre and post-synaptic
receptors
and components of their signal
transduction pathway
and putting that all together we were
eventually able to
come up with some sort of rudimentary
idea of how it is
that the initial contact between a motor
axons growth cone
and a newly formed maya tube turns in
to this elaborate highly specialized
adult neuromuscular junction
what are some of the iterate iterative
intercellular interactions between the
nerve and the muscle
that pass information back and forth
often using
the synaptic cleft as a molecular
bulletin board to pattern
the formation of the eventually mature
neuromuscular junction
now as this work um came to fruition
uh not to say it's finished there's
still many unanswered questions
um i became interested again
in going back to what had fascinated me
initially which is
the issue of synaptic specificity how it
is
that an axon entering into an area with
many potential postsynaptic targets
manages to find one particular one on
which to form synapses thereby
generating the information processing
circuits that we all want to understand
we tried to use the neuromuscular
junction for this purpose
goping feng was part of one of those
efforts and the results were interesting
but it pretty soon became apparent that
to really look at how neurons wire up
in specific ways to form neural circuits
we needed to study more complicated
neural circuits
and so we pretty rapidly settled on the
retina
as the model to study so the retina as
you know
is outside the skull but is part of the
brain
it is not a piece of film as people
thought once
but rather comprises many cell types
that established complicated and highly
stereotyped circuits
and just like the neuromuscular junction
it affords advantages
that make it possible to ask questions
at a level of detail here
that you would like to ask about areas
like the cortex or the hippocampus or
the cerebellum
but can't really because of technical
reasons it's more accessible
it has clear borders you know exactly
what you're cutting out
it has no long-range inputs it has a
very well organized set of
laminae and sublaminae in which the
neurons are arranged and so forth
and so as i said that has become our
model system of choice
and our exclusive model for the past
decade
so let me give you a quick sense of how
the retina works
it comprises three layers of cells
separated by two layers of synapses that
are called plexiform layers
the outer layer has rod and cone
photoreceptors
they form synapses on interneurons that
are of three classes horizontal bipolar
and emigrant cells
i'll say more about them in a minute and
those cells
make synapses in the inner synaptic
layer and retinal ganglion cells
whose axons run through the optic nerve
to other centers of the brain for
further processing
now the reason this is a great model for
studying
circuit development and synaptic
specificity
is that there are actually many types of
interneurons and many types of retinal
ganglion cells
so that in a mouse dozens of types of
neurites
intermingle in what at birth is a very
very
small space so everybody's within
filipodial reach of everybody else
and then they sort out to form the
complex circuits that enable retinal
ganglion cells to no longer be light
detectors
but rather feature detectors with each
type
selectively stimulated by some visual
feature
like motion motion in a particular
direction
color contrast edges and so forth
and so we set out to ask whether we
could find
some of the recognition molecules that
enable this specific connectivity
and took a transgenic approach
generating or obtaining transgenic lines
that would selectively mark one or a few
of these retinal cell types
giving us access so that we could look
at them
target them for physiological recording
look at their morphology
access them so that we could manipulate
their genomes
and sort them isolate them and purify
them by facts so that we could ask
what sorts of recognition molecules they
expressed
and over a period of i would say almost
a dozen years
we ended up identifying a set of
recognition molecules
and transcription factors that play some
roles
in setting up the circuitry
that endows three types of retinal
ganglion cells called w3b
jrgcs and oods with
their feature detecting processes
properties sorry um
so this was very few out of the many
neuronal types
and in none of these cases could i say
that we come to a satisfying conclusion
so it became apparent maybe five or so
years ago
that doing things in this retail fashion
was not going to get the job done in my
lifetime or even
in the lifetime of my students and
instead it was going to be necessary
to find some way to comprehensively
classify and characterize the neurons so
that we would know what
all the types were and know what all the
important molecules developmentally the
recognition molecules and
transcription factors were and find out
among other things just how many types
of retinal cells there are that we have
to deal with
so this was a fantasy that was made real
by the discovery of methods for high
throughput single cell
rna sequencing and it was such a great
idea that was i
uh discovered three times independently
uh
in three different labs all more or less
simultaneously
uh once by evan mccosko in
a steve carroll's laboratory at harvard
once by alan klein and mark kirschner's
level a laboratory also at harvard an
interesting story there
and the third time by a group that uh
assude high profile publications but
instead started a company
and marketed what's called the 10x
system which is the one that
virtually everybody uses now and at this
point they could probably buy cell press
at any rate i've put a drop seek in
color here
because we got involved at an early
stage in evan's project
because he saw the value of using the
retina
as a way to perfect the method and
validate it
based on the features i've mentioned
that we know so much about
the cell types and what genes they
express
and so i'm at this point i think
everybody knows how single cell rna seq
works and probably half the people in
the audience use it
so i'll just give you sort of a 30
second
one slide introduction in essence the
method involves dissociating a tissue
isolating the cells or more recently the
nuclei
and passing them through a microfluidic
device
in which a single cell gets encapsulated
in a nano liter size
oil droplet with a single bead
and those beads then are half the cell
and the particle uh in lysis buffer the
cell immediately lyses
its mrna is captured by oligonucleotides
on the bead
and the emulsion is then broken um and
all of the messenger rnas are turned
into cdnas
amplified by amplified by polarized
chain reaction
and sequenced together in a single tube
and that's really the key to this method
uh instead of uh needing to let's say
sequence uh 2000 single cells with 2 000
test tubes and an untold number of
graduate students and hours
you can do the whole thing in a single
tube in a more or less automated way
and then computationally there are ways
to
separate out the transcripts and pool
them into those that came from each
individual cell
so here is a display
of the first experiment that evan did on
retina
uh it's the compilation of about a dozen
runs totaling
almost 45 000 cells and this is a disney
plot that many of you
are probably familiar with in which uh
something like forty four thousand eight
hundred and eight dots are arranged
and their arrangements and their colors
tell you what the
computer thought were cells that were
transcriptomically similar enough
to be considered candidates to be single
cell types or small groups of closely
related cell types
and because this was the retina we could
look at genes selectively expressed by
each
of these clusters and ask whether they
made sense as
individual cell types and to make a long
story short they did one cluster would
be rods one plus two would be cone
several clustered would be emigrant
cells
and so forth it worked
but it was limited and you can see that
most clearly
in that there were only 39 clusters and
we already knew
at this point that there were going to
be more than that
at least 60 types of retinal cells
and the problem was that even though
evan was profiling an immense number of
cells the vast majority of them 70 to 80
percent were rod photoreceptors
and so there weren't enough cells in
this population of the very rare types
especially rare types that were similar
to other rare types
to have the computational power to
separate them into individual clusters
or cell types and so what we did then
was to go on
and develop transgenic methods to
isolate
the three most heterogeneous classes
that i mentioned already
the bipolar interneurons the amacrine
interneurons and the retinal ganglion
cells
and escalate isolate enough of them to
take the project to a conclusion
and here's what we found over a few
years a total of 15 types of bipolar
cells
46 types of retinal ganglion cells
and an absolutely terrifying 63 types of
american cells
so right away you get some evidence that
what i said is true that the retina
really is as complicated as
almost any other part of the brain these
are similar numbers to what
the allen institute said uh finds in
motor cortex or visual cortex
and we were able to go into each of
these clusters and just as we did with
evan
find genes selectively expressed by one
or another
of the clusters that's shown in these
dot plots and then using situ
hybridization
and immunohistochemistry to ask whether
the molecularly defined clusters
had a morphological homogeneity or a
morphological identity
and in some cases a physiological
identity since
clearly cell types defined by purely
molecular criteria
would be a very limited interest to most
neurobiologists
if they didn't correspond to cell types
defined by things that most
neurobiologists care about
and the answer basically was good for
the retina at least
in every case we studied which is not
all of them but many of them
we were able to find a one-to-one match
of
molecules to morphology to physiology
and we can come back to this in
discussion it's not entirely clear
that this will be true of other areas
like the cortex
in which so much development is
experience dependent
but it is true in the retina so to
summarize
that early work then um by a couple of
years ago
we had a atlas of the mouse retina
comprising around 130 neuronal types
and around 10 non-neuronal types so a
total of 140.
and it's interesting to note that the
number of types
identified and characterized about
doubled over a period of 10 years
and of course lots of people were
working during that decade
including some beautiful work on high
throughput electron microscopy
but i think it's fair to say that the
biggest increase came from
single cell transcriptomics um and at
this point
uh one would never be shocked to find
one or two or three or four more cell
types
but i believe we have a fairly
substantial
and reasonably complete cell atlas of
the mouse retina
and the fact that we can do that and
show this harmonization of molecular
physiological and functional criteria
i think um has helped people in other
areas that are
less accessible and more difficult to
deal with to go on and try to
continue this enterprise there so as
this came to completion
um we decided that we would try to use
the atlas to do some interesting
biology and over the past few years
we've worked in five areas
that i'll just describe very briefly and
then sort of focus in on a few of them
so the first is development which is of
course where we came from
a second is selective vulnerability can
we use
the multiplicity of cell types in the
retina
to look into the very general issue of
why following
injury or neurodegenerative disease some
different cell types are able to survive
or regenerate better than other types
and ultimately can we use that
information to figure out ways to make
vulnerable genes more resilient we also
asked whether we could
use the mouse atlas as a starting point
to look at
human retina with a stop along the way
with non-human primates
um and the particular question here was
to see if we could reveal special
features of the fovea
uh the primate specific at least amongst
mammals central part of the retina that
mediates high acuity vision
and with those atlases in hand we could
look at where
um genes that have been implicated in
diseases
of the retina are expressed what cells
in the retina and we've gone on to now
look
and develop an atlas of the entire rest
of the eye so we can ask whether
genes that predispose to retinal disease
are expressed in retinal neurons or
perhaps neurons
in the anterior segment the trabecular
meshwork
the ciliary body and so forth and then
finally
we're just beginning to look at the
evolutionary question using the retina
as a model to ask how conserved our cell
classes and by that i mean in this case
photoreceptors
interneurons output neurons and how
conserved
particularly our cell types among
vertebrates a question not
unlike that asked about genes but it can
also be asked about cell types
so today i'm going to focus primarily on
the first two of these questions and
depending on how fast i talk
say just a little bit about evolution at
the end
so for development um there are many
questions
about diversification expression of
adhesion molecules transcription factors
effects of experience on the development
of the retina at the molecular level
and we've looked at all of these but i'm
going to focus here just on the one
on how cell types diversify
and so by background let me say just a
few words about how these cell
classes in the retina diversify and we
know quite a bit about that because
uh more than 30 years ago three groups
scott frasers
um christine holt and bill harris's and
connie sepgos here at harvard
um showed in different ways and in
different species
that their multi potential progenitors
that can divide and give rise
successively to the different cell
classes retinal ganglion cells
horizontal cells
rod photoreceptors amacrine cells
cone photoreceptors and so forth and
they do that in roughly the birth order
that was already known so the first
uh progeny are cones actually in retinal
ganglion cells the last progeny
are rods and mueller glial cells
we also have some idea of how this
progenitor changes
and the most influential model there is
connie sepko's
competence model in which she posited
and she and many others have now gotten
evidence for the idea
that these progenitors change their
state
as they move along and throw off
post-mitotic cells
and as a consequence of in
intrinsic changes and extrinsic
influences coming perhaps from earlier
born cells
they become capable now or maybe even
committed to
generating different cell classes and
then i say the third big idea is one
that maybe bill harris is most
responsible for
and that is the idea that the choices
are maybe not
completely deterministic but rather
stochastic that what's happening as
progenitors mature
is that they change the frequencies with
which they're likely to throw off
particular
progeny so at first they're most likely
to give rise to a retinal ganglion cell
much less likely to give rise to other
types at the end the other way around
so i mention all this to draw
contrast with what we know about the
generation of cell types the 46 types of
retinal ganglion cells
the 63 types of american cells and so
forth
and there we know nothing about the
progenitor nothing about competence
nothing about stochasticity partly
because people didn't really know what
the types were when they were doing
these
initial classic experiments partly
because to the extent they did know the
types
they could define them only
physiologically which wasn't much use
for an inquiry like this
and so we decided to see if we could use
our atlas as a basis for looking at the
diversification
of one class the retinal ganglion cells
and the way we did that was to first ask
about two extreme models so we're now
looking post-mitotically
and we posited two extreme models about
how these ganglion cells could
diversify we here being karthik shecker
who led the computational effort
and irene whitney who led the
experimental effort
so one extreme would be that there are
actually 46 types of progenitors
each of which is committed to give rise
to a particular type of ganglion cell
and then go on to give rise to a host of
other
cell classes and types either in a
deterministic way or not
and the other extreme would be that all
ganglion cells initially post
mitotically are identical
and then they diversify in some stepwise
fashion eventually forming
all the 46 types and so the way we
tried to look at those extremes and
points in between
was to look first at the adult atlas
and then go earlier earlier earlier
earlier earlier
and ask how many clusters we saw by
similar
and other computational methods at each
time
starting from embryonic day 13 which is
the earliest time at which a large
number of retinal ganglion cells are
becoming post-mitotic
all the way through adulthood and the
upshot was
that the number of clusters increased
over time and increased several fold
and the clusters became not only more
numerous but became more clustery that
is they become
transcriptomically more separated from
each other a point
i'll come back to in a minute and so
these data
along with a number of other
considerations controls that i won't go
into let us tentatively
exclude the model of there being 46
types of
progenitors each initially committed to
a particular type
so it was either stepwise or somewhere
in between
and we next asked whether that stepwise
diversification was specific and
determinant that is
is each individual post-mitotic cell
committed to give rise
to a small set of adult types
or is it non-specific are the individual
cells initially capable of giving rising
to a number of cells with overlaps
amongst the early cells in what
adult progeny they can eventually give
rise to
and one simple way to distinguish those
alternatives is to
transcriptomically match the early
clusters to the light clusters
and in a specific and deterministic
scheme you would expect that
each early cluster would share much of
its transcriptomic similarity
with a specific set of adult types
whereas
there would be no such relationship if
there was complete non-specificity
and so we'd look at that and hear just
two examples and the upshot is no it's
not completely random
but it's certainly not completely
deterministic
the initial transcriptomic types here
clusters i should say here looking at
embryonic day 13 and 14
seem to share transcriptomic similarity
with many different adult types
so again we can tentatively rule out a
very specific
model and say instead there's some sort
of
non-specificity and then next and last
for this part of the talk
we wanted to ask what this sort of
non-specificity was and what i mean by
that is
the analysis i just described is at the
level of clusters
so we see a level of indeterminacy at
the level of clusters
but it's possible that the
determinancy is much greater at the
level of
individual cells that it is it could be
that the early clusters are made up of
partially
overlapping sets of individual cells
each of which is determined to give rise
to one or
very few eventual adult types
alternatively it could be that even the
individual cells within the clusters
are indeterminate and multi-potential
now the only way to really answer that
question
in a satisfying way is to find a way to
visualize
a post-mitotic cell follow it through to
adulthood
figure out what it is and then run time
back in a time machine
and do it over again several times and
see whether
a cell is truly multi-potential now at
least in my lab
that isn't yet possible and so we took
an indirect computational approach using
a method
called optimal transport which was
actually
invented more than a century ago for
completely different purposes
but was then repurposed by eric lander
and his colleagues at the broad
institute
to be used with transcriptomic data
and the basic idea is to look at a cell
by cell
basis at how the transcriptomic mass
of an individual cell is apportioned
to other cells at later stages so it's a
sort of
computational lineage diagram it is
inferential
but it's the best we can do and
using that method um what karthik found
was that indeed
the newborn retinal ganglion cells are
very multi-potential each one
gives transcriptomic mass to something
like
10 or 12 adult types
and then that potential decreases over
time
until it becomes one in adulthood
because at that point of course every
cell has become what it's going to be
and the diagrams here on the right are
meant to show you
that it's many many cells that are
multi-potential most of them
not just a single small subset of cells
so at least inferentially we can rule
out this idea
of there being cohorts of
determined cells but rather conclude
that cells are truly multi-potential at
an early stage
and their potential then decreases in a
stepwise fashion
until they eventually each individual
cell matures into one of the
46 types now with this model in mind
we can begin to look at whether the
groups of individual cells end up
maturing into adult types that are
related to each other
and one of many ways of visualizing that
is in what's called a sankey plot
in which one plots the
let's say the paths of maximal
transcriptomic mass
from groups of cells uh now calculated
by optimal transport
to groups of cells at each subsequent
stage
and to make a long story short the
answer is sort of
for some subclasses of retinal ganglion
cells ones that
express tbr2 or neurod2 in adulthood
there seems to be very restricted a
group of early progenitors that mature
into those types
via stepwise diversification and fade
uncoupling
for other types there's a less clear
pathway and so the idea now is that one
can use
sankey plots and go back to these early
stages
and look for transcription factors that
might be expressed at those early stages
that are potential fate determinants of
groups of adult types
and of course with those transcription
factors in hand it ought to be possible
to use mouse
genetics to test those ideas and find
out whether
there is something about these early
multi-potential but maybe partially
committed progenitors
and ask what happens if you manipulate
them or knock them out
so let me move on to the second topic
now of selective vulnerability
and the model here is one of optic nerve
crush
and there we've done a series of
experiments in close collaboration with
zhigong he
who is a real expert in this area his
lab is a children's hospital
and the paradigm is that if you crush
the optic nerve in a mouse
and sever the exons eighty percent of
the ganglion cells die within two weeks
and there's almost no regeneration of
accents
some limited regeneration can be
provoked with a number of
interventions several of which have been
pioneered by gigon
and so what we started by asking is
whether this survival
is a stochastic process that is
is it that some cells live and some die
maybe because they were active when the
nerve was crushed or because they were
near a blood vessel
or because they had a little more
trophic factor or could there be a cell
type basis for selective vulnerability
at the limit could it be that 80 percent
of the types
completely die and twenty percent of the
types completely survive
so in the first step we use some of the
transgenic lines that i mentioned
and indeed found dramatic differences
amongst
groups of types so a subclass called
alpha ganglion cells
survive very well one of the
intrinsically photosensitive ganglion
cell types survive very well
and other types survive very poorly tuj1
is a marker for all the types just
confirming
that only 20 of the types were left at
this period two weeks after nerve crush
so with the cell atlas in hand we
decided to ask
this question of all the cell types and
more importantly
find out what those cells were
expressing and whether there were
differences
between the vulnerable and the resilient
types
and so the way we did that was calculate
the
frequency of all 46 types
based on our single cell data and
we cross checked that against a lot of
histological analysis so we have some
confidence in the frequencies
uh determined by uh transcriptomics and
then we cut the optic nerve
did the whole thing again two weeks
later and then divided one by the other
looking at the fraction of each of the
46 tell types that survived
over two weeks and there were two main
findings
one is there are indeed dramatic
differences some resilient types
survive to the tune of almost 90 percent
some vulnerable types die to the tune of
almost 95
and second it's not a binary division
there's rather a continuum
between the most resilient and the most
vulnerable types something we didn't
really know from the
original study because we were able to
look at so few types
so we could then look into the rna-seq
data
and look for genes that would be
selectively expressed
by resilient or susceptible types either
before injury or each of six time points
that we looked at
after injury and the news was good and
bad
the good news is that there were some
types that were expressed in some
resilient
or some susceptible types but not the
other way around
the bad news was that we found no genes
at all
sadly whose expression was confined
completely to all resilient types and no
susceptible types are the other way
around
nor any genes whose level of expression
correlated
with resilience or vulnerability
nonetheless
we were able to pick some promising
candidate resilience genes
and knock them out or some promising
candidate vulnerability genes and over
express them in resilient cells
using aavs for overexpression and aav
based crispr method for knockout
and indeed in some cases both improved
ganglion cell survival
so it wasn't a huge effect none of these
are running to the clinic
but it was some validation that this
could be a good method
for identifying targets that might
ultimately be
of some therapeutic value
so i'll tell you now um what we're doing
as a next step and this again is worked
by nick tran
and jacoby and wen zhunyan i forgot to
mention that
karthik shekhar was involved in the
first step
and the idea here is to now go the next
step
and ask how these therapeutic
interventions improve
ganglion cells survival and regeneration
with the hope of finding out something
about the mechanism underlying these
effects
and so what we've ended up using are
three interventions that chigong and his
colleagues
have pioneered which are very robust and
repeated multiple times one is
enhancing mtor signaling by deleting the
mtor endogenous inhibitor p10
one is enhancing jack stat signaling by
deleting conditionally
its endogenous inhibitor sox3
and a third is over expressing cntf
you can see here the enhanced
regeneration uh in these interventions
and here
from one of jigong's papers uh the
enhanced axonal regeneration
in this case in the double knockout
conditional
of p10 and so the idea then has been to
do these interventions and then isolate
retinal ganglion cells for single cell
transcriptomics
and see if we can find what genes are
expressed
in the cases where there's been
intervention
and not otherwise now we've recently
augmented this inquiry with a beautiful
method that ann jacoby came up with
in which she's able to actually
selectively label
in a retina those cells that regenerate
from those cells that survive but don't
regenerate
by in a really arduous surgical
manipulation
injecting a fluorescent tracer in the
optic nerve so it'll be picked up by
regenerating axons
but not by those axons whose stumps have
survived
but haven't regenerated and you can get
a sense of that down here here's the
fluorescent tracer
and in this whole mount these little red
dots uh
are the retrogradely labeled
regenerating
ganglion cells many controls that i'm
not going into
and so what ann can now do is use two
labels to isolate
those retinal ganglion cells that have
regenerated
from those that survived but most likely
did not regenerate
and the types there are actually quite
interesting i'll say just a word about
this
in this double conditional knockout with
cntf
it looks like actually almost all of the
types that survive regenerate
and why that's interesting is that maybe
that in this case regeneration is not
cell type specific
but there's something magic happening to
some of the cells of many types that
changes their state
and allows them to regenerate now
whether their cell state is a
the cause or the consequence of
regeneration of course remains to be
worked out
but at any rate looking into the genes
um the idea here
is to combine all the interventions
all the types the crush with no
intervention
and then re-cluster the cells in a
number of ways
and and nick and wengen have tested four
different methods
in one they cluster cells by the type of
intervention
in other by their transcriptomic
similarity
overall whether it be cell types or
states
another in which they emphasize states
without cell type labels
and another in which they're clustered
based on
what are called regulons that is
co-expression of transcription factors
an expression of genes that are
predicted to be the targets of those
transcription factors
and this analysis is still underway but
remarkably the
preliminary result is that all four
methods have generated
a set of similar modules something that
i never would have expected
yet seems fairly likely to be true
and i'll show you just one example here
by the
regulon method and so here are the cells
sort of sloppily re-clustered by that
method
and here are three modules that is
clusters along the bottom sets of
genes along the right and you can see
that these two clusters selectively
express this set of genes
here and here and you can see the cells
that contribute to those modules
numbers one two and three are largely
albeit not entirely
uh non-overlapping groups and so here
are the three modules module one
is enriched in genes
that evoke cell death and apoptosis like
ddit3
and the cells that contribute to that
module
are enriched in the vulnerable ganglion
cell types and types that appear to be
on their way out module two down here
is enriched in genes that have been
implicated in neural development
for example alcam and bdnf and the cells
uh in this module whoops over here
are enriched in looking at anne's
results from the retrograde labeling
cells that appear to be surviving but
not regenerating
and then module three of
in which cells in the cells contributing
to that molecule are enriched in the
regenerating
group um are also enriched from a
transcriptomic level
in genes that have been implicated in
axonal growth and regeneration
so the idea now is to look particularly
into this regeneration module
and ask whether manipulating any genes
in that module can actually promote
external regeneration
and so here are three genes that ann and
nick have tested so far
you can see their expression in
regenerators compared to survivors
from ann's retrograde labeling data
confirms their identity as being
selectively expressed
in those ganglion cells that regenerate
over those that survive but don't
regenerate
and indeed the initial data suggests
that all three of them when
overexpressed using an aav
can promote some level of axonal
regeneration
so i've left myself five minutes um and
that's good because i now get to say a
few words about evolution
and as i said the idea here is to do
or initiate a project to do for cell
types more or less what people have done
in so much detail and so beautifully for
the conservation and evolution of genes
and gene families and we think the
retina again is a good place to do this
because its basic plan is conserved
essentially
amongst all vertebrates they pretty much
all have the same six classes of
photoreceptors
three types of interneurons ganglion
cells
one type of intrinsic glial cell the
mueller glia
and so what i've told you about so far
our
mouse transcriptomics but we've expanded
that now
to look at the retinas of a large number
of other species a number that i hope
continues to grow
we have incomplete cell atlases
for them but enough to begin to look
at evolutionary conservation of at least
some of these cell classes and so
if we look first uh at the classes
uh in a four-way comparison that wen
zhenyan has done looking at
chick human macaque and mouse what we
can see
is that what was known to be the
morphological and physiological
conservation of classes is
perfectly maintained at the molecular
level
so for example a bipolar cell
of a chick is transcriptomically more
similar to the bipolar cell of a mouse
macaque or human than it is to any other
chick retinal class so
that's that's good that's gratifying
and now really the big question where
we've only begun
is to ask what happens to conservation
at the cell type level
and here's just an initial result so
re-clustering in these four species
we can ask the degree to which types are
conserved among species and one very
simple initial metric
is to ask in the re-clustering how many
species contribute to each of these
clusters
and i think if you look just at the
colors here you can get a sense that
there's more
mixing for the immigrant cells than for
the retinal ganglion cells
and that's borne out arithmetically
the number of species that contributes
to each cluster is greater for
all of the four other neuronal types
than it is for ganglion cells there are
many confounds here
about uh type number and so forth but i
think
uh the overall conclusion is pretty
rodust
and and so it sort of leads to a model
in which
the outer retina is a conserved set of
processors
that's been evolutionarily conserved and
where evolution
may be acting at the most is
at the level of the retinal ganglion
cells where this processed information
is now transferred to the rest of the
brain and it may be in the variation
among retinal ganglion cell types
that we will see the most evolutionary
tinkering to let's say match
the capabilities of uh each animal's
vision
to the ecological niche uh that it
occupies
so with that um i'm at an end i want to
thank
the people who have done the work i've
put in green here those who contributed
to the unpublished work that i described
but it's been a big group included in
this list of
people from collaborators labs of which
there are many this is the most
collaborative
project i've ever been involved in and i
just want to say what a pleasure it's
been to collaborate
with these other terrific scientists and
the students in their laboratory
i always end with a picture of kahal but
it's particularly i would say
suitable and appropriate here because he
in around 1880
started on the project of cell type
classification
and it's sort of fun to think that we
are using different tools
to do his bidding even now so thank you
very much
so i will stop sharing and
there we go
well let me um first of all let me let
that
let me uh start a round of applause are
we how can we do this
i don't see a um i don't see an applause
button on my zoom to but
i will start applauding you and with my
real hands
uh for that uh absolutely wonderful
wonderful really clear
uh talk josh that was that was fabulous
and
um you know the thing about kahal
was he really
uh he he he was the superb anatomist
but he was always thinking about
function like what is what does this all
mean and you know and you are in that
same
class of anatomist you want to
understand what does it all mean
in terms of circuits and development and
and now even evolution
and so you you're definitely following
in his footsteps
so we're going to have um some uh
questions um and answers
questions and josh will give answers um
and so the first question
is uh from fenwang uh can i think we can
unmute you uh can we can we try doing
that
uh can you hear me yeah
i just said hi josh beautiful talk uh
just wanted to ask whether or not
activity do you see activity playing any
role at all
in cell type specification
so um we
i didn't talk about it but we um blocked
visual activity postnatally um
in in a couple different ways uh two
different mutants and just by dark
rearing from birth
and of course a lot of diversification
is done by birth but we see
no effect on the remaining
diversification
and maybe more surprising is that the
effects on gene expression
are shockingly modest
and we know that activity plays a huge
role in the
central wiring of retinal ganglion cell
axons
and so we just need to look into what
those genes are
that are affected by activity and we
haven't done that yet
great thank you
just uh can i maybe i can ask you a
question
about the um the regeneration the
the regeneration work and the axons um
are you
seeing this as a way of understanding
more
about the um the programming
of the cell identity or are you actually
thinking about this therapeutically
that there's you might be a way of
promoting axonal regeneration i i guess
i mean first as a basic science question
the mechanism is fascinating and it's a
general question for all
neurodegenerative diseases right i mean
you know
why do you have let's say an sod-1
mutation all your neurons
in als but motor neurons selectively die
but yes i think there's some potential
therapeutically
we look the course to see whether after
injury
um the cell type identity is compromised
do they lose their type specific
features
and by and large no they don't
we have a question from ayano matsushima
maybe i can just read the questions the
question is
is the resilience susceptibility
determined by the genetic
profile predetermined at the stage of
ancestry progenitor or expressed just
before the injury
or induced in response to the injury
okay so you know at least tentatively
we're assuming there's only one type of
progenitor so
when the differences appear as step wise
when in that stepwise progression the
vulnerability
is instantiated we have no idea
certainly in the very small number of
genes we've tested some are included
that are expressed in
let's say resilient types prior to
injury
others are expressed only after injury
so i think it'll be a mixed fact
but of course even those that are
expressed in particular cell types only
after injury
are expressed in those particular cell
types because of some sort of
pre-programming that had to be there
before injury
so um thank you we have the question
from alan jason off why don't we just
unmute alan you can ask this
hello hi hi hi josh beautiful talk
um i wanted to ask you about um the
relationship between the markers of the
cell classes that you've identified and
um their function anatomy as you know
from
other uh other studies including your
own
um when you look at the lists of genes
that are
best uh you know that are that are most
predictive of the different classes that
you've found
do they make sense do you see channels
adhesion proteins scaffolding proteins
and so on
is there any logic that you can decipher
maybe post-facto from
what you found i hate to say this but so
far no
you know it looks like the genes that
are selectively expressed in one type
rather than another are everything from
you know metabolic genes to channels to
recognition molecules to pumps
you know so amongst them there clearly
have to be
genes that are important for development
and function
but they're not super enriched
that's that's neat um are they
definitely different cell types then as
a
you know as a neurophysiologist would
define them
well there you know what we've done is
take
genes that are selectively expressed and
we just take the ones that are most
selectively expressed no matter what
they are
and use in situ or immunohistochemistry
to see whether
the cells that express those are
a selective a specific type by let's say
morphological criteria
and in every case we've done yes they
are yeah
i'd say all right well cool um certainly
food for a thought
thanks yeah kind of a disappointment
frankly you know i figured you'd look at
these gene lists and the secret of the
cell would be revealed but
that's what we all want um but i guess
the lesson of biology is often that uh
you know it's all in statistics and uh
you know the
the deeper logic the deeper meaning
isn't there as mick jagger said you
don't always get what you want
thanks again we have a question from
helen shu who's actually a postdoc in my
lab
uh can you comment on how mouse retina
seems capable of doing higher functions
for example direction selectivity
that macaque retina cannot seem to do
does the mouse retina have more types of
interneurons or more complex circuits
um interesting yeah so the mouse retina
seems to have
lots more types of retinal ganglion
cells
than primate retina and their
frequencies
are not hugely different from each other
as opposed to
uh primates in which you know 80 plus
percent of the ganglion cells are [ __ ]
cells
and so the tentative idea is
that for lower vertebrates that send
most of the retinal output to the
superior colliculus they do
a ton of preprocessing whereas when you
get a cortex
you sacrifice a few milliseconds in
hardwired speed
and do more processing in the cortex
that gives you more flexibility
okay um we have a question from
ching zhang who someone else i
collaborate with
um wonderful talk do cells with
multi-potential differentiation have a
spatial distribution feature at a
certain age
so i don't know that but the retina is
very weird
in the sense that every little piece of
the retina seems to have a complete
complement
of all 130 cell types give or take
so that and of course it makes sense
in that it's not like you only see
things going up out of the left side of
your eye
and things going right out of your right
visual field
so my guess would be that neither do the
progenitors have
a major bias to one or another part of
the retina
okay thank you so this will be the last
questions from jill crittenden
who i work with every day is retinal
degeneration disorder in retinal
degeneration disorders is there a
preferential loss of genes that define
the
the rgc types um
yeah so you know we've only really
looked at nerve crush
which is not a big public health problem
we would love to do this in mouse models
of glaucoma and actually even in human
glaucoma and ask
but in optic nerve crush there are
changes in gene expression but they do
not lose their type identity
they get sick and die and when they die
they're the type that they are
okay well let's give another uh
pink wants to know if he can ask a
question live quo ping we will allow you
it's one last live
question live from live from newton
massachusetts
thank you guys one [ __ ] i i was
wondering whether
across the retina from you know
peripheral to center
the same type of you know
cell type do you see any differences uh
topographic differences are gradient or
anything gene expression
so there are some differences in
frequency
of types um
i mean in in primates of course the the
the density of cells is much greater in
the central retina and the phobia is
very different from the peripheral
retina
in mouse there's a very very very modest
gradient in density
and for each individual cell type there
may be some gradient in density
uh some central peripheral some dorsal
ventral
we've seen this with a number of types
rachel wong has seen it with a number of
types
but they're not huge really you know
nothing that
uh let's say challenges the general
conclusion that every part of the retina
has every cell type
thank you i'm going to make one more
exception because we have a question
from our very good colleague helen
barbus from across the river
um alan should we should we uh unmute
you
no well well
i'm not quite sure that worked but she's
asking in the cortex some neurons in
specific areas share features that
appear to render them vulnerable to
the to disease can you identify clusters
of features and vulnerable neurons
well i was showing you our best bet
there
and yes of course we are hoping that
some of what we see
would be transferable to
neurodegenerative diseases and of course
people are now doing this a lot in
neurodegenerative diseases
alzheimer's probably more than others
you know i'd say the last part i talked
about where we're trying to look at
gene expression modules after
interventions
is partly a response to the fact that
although we found
interesting genes we didn't find you
know
perfect markers of resilience and
vulnerability we're hoping maybe that
some pathway analysis will be more
productive
okay well josh thank you so much
wonderful talk
wonderful answers to questions and uh
let's
again we don't seem to have an applause
button here on our zoom
just know that we are all applauding you
right now thanks so much
bye-bye everybody bye-bye
congratulations again